[Music]
good morning guys
it's another day at home but not for
Casey he just got back home from grocery
shopping with his parents and you also
went to Home Depot because we couldn't
fully finish mounting the TV stuff so
you have to go get some stuff and then
also Papa tan is going to be installing
an outlet for our big day in our master
bathroom but look at this clear the
score it's the madhouse out there while
they were gone I was cleaning up I did
some dishes made some coffee but yes
oh that is for this thing this or the
knife nice so you put it together and
then the knives go into inside the slot
inside these blocks put them they'll go
in here we just haven't set it up yet so
how is it out there for you that's good
perfect
everyone washing hands nice and
responsible what happened yeah I need a
real big one all right what's up guys
just finished cooking and that's the
first time I cooked in this house I kind
of missed out on yeah and this time I'm
documenting the first time cooking here
the thing you kind of didn't want to
count it because it was just pasta and
stuff out of the jar so you were like
it's not real cooking because I'm not
chopping anything well technically then
I'm not really cooking today either
because that we got this Korean BBQ
pre-marinated thing from a Korean
grocery store so yes I didn't really
cook today isn't it all right okay true
true but yeah this is what I came up
with
and he's already gone done that's gone
yeah well my dad's on the construction
worker time schedule right now it says
lunch breaking at 15 minutes he's got to
get back to work all right so this is
our first surgical surgery for the house
my dad's put some put a hole in wall
ready Oh true true true this one's a
real surgery that was like a little
patch up job this is so what are you
doing right now for us so we're gonna
run the electrical wire all the way
around these for free right there are
toilets like right through this wall and
what we're doing is we're trying to have
an outlet inside the bathroom where the
toilet is so that we could have an
outlet to plug our bidet in because
right now we're just running a wire
that's what we're plugging the bidet
into which is running into here so now
we're just going to power from here and
bring it over to the bidet this is how'd
you learn all this stuff that means your
site has zero common sense probably take
this really tight my goal is to put this
thing through and I'm gonna hook this
wire back out oh I see oh that's why you
needed the string you're fishing for the
hooks you fishing for the hook so stick
it down there the whole flake is really
I hope that's the stake no stay there
trying to stay still so we're going to
hate this cuz I'm going to speed this in
I hope I can actually alright so while
the guys are doing that with the
electrical stuff I wanted to document
this momentous occasion where I finally
get to do the first load of laundry and
I only have enough detergent for one
load because I ordered more detergent
and it's coming in tomorrow but till
then there's a lot of laundry cook cute
the temper that I got I've been waiting
for this moment so check this out it
actually has wheels so I can just wheel
it on over right across the hall hotel
construction so laundry look at this I'm
so happy and then BOOM here's the
laundry room
oh man this is kind of sad how this gets
me
uber excited I don't know man am i weird
am I really weird and I'm really really
really excited to do my first load in
the new and I show you guys already I
don't know if I did but the doors open
away from each other
okay open-heart surgery here we go
[Music]
sweetie he's plastic pipe actually yeah
this is really on PC yeah yeah singing
she Steve was telling me about that
there's nothing like he was dripping
that keep hearing dripping oh really oh
yeah maybe you can know there's a
there's a stud right here you can't
exactly fit the box for electrical and
so we're gonna I'm trying to widen in
there we're gonna make the hole a little
bit bigger and try to push it up against
this on this side and up and away from
the pipe on the other side and see we
just wedging in between see what happens
see that's the stud there's the pipe
meanwhile in the laundry room the washer
is done and now it's time to move over
to the dryer exciting stuff
[Music]
we are abandoning that previous thought
of trying to wedge it in there we are
going to not put the electrical next to
that pipe because we just don't want to
crack that bike feels kind of scary you
don't know what that place for either so
we're gonna make another hole another
square and hopefully this one checks out
we kind of dug our there drill in and it
checks out and goes all the way through
so there we go alright this is some real
homeowner type stuff this is the type of
stuff that my dad's always warned me
about and you gotta learn this stuff
yeah I learn to change your own
lightbulbs yeah yeah not really I'm
calling a plumber or a fixture on toilet
I don't know why it my dad's always been
able to like do this stuff around the
house growing up and I've watched him do
it a lot of times that I've assisted
many times just like I am right now but
and I've never gravitated towards this
stuff but now that I am a homeowner
myself I am looking and watching and
studying and learning taking notes in a
different kind of through a different
panel lens it's a lot though
overwhelming
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
beautiful tinnitus waving oh nice but I
had him in the hole yeah yeah big ol
hole next door maybe we can just use
like a glue gun and then glue it that'd
be cool
but now ya connect that same side hey my
dad's a lot more handier than I thought
he was I knew he was handy
he's never I've never seen me do
electrical things before I know you as
an engineer literal engineer but like he
did like a lot of wood like work growing
up like I seen him inside cut wood and
hammered things together build shell
huge shelves that were like really
extravagant and like had a nice molding
and stuff and then he like dug a pond in
our backyard and had like a whole like I
don't think he was invisible for that
true I don't know I don't know why I
just oh there goes the no electric
imagine yeah that's how I also often ask
you did you learn I learned a lot I did
learn a lot because you were telling me
earlier that when you were younger your
dad was trying to teach you things and
that the whole time you're just like
yeah yeah
Karen I'm here but now that you're a man
of the house yeah your own house did you
soak anything yet I'm watching him
through different a different set of
lenses
good job Bubba oh you bought one of
those things what it came with the
intention of doing this thank you but no
electricity
what is the where'd they go oh they're
over there see I'm helping yep just kick
Nick's hopper I'm the assistant to the
assistant regional magic manager oh no
no I actually have wire cutters we do
yes instead of messing up the scissors
let me go get the thingamabob are you
guys doing this is what you do during
the quarantine yoga oh I didn't notice
Isis same color
that's funny how that does hurt
[Music]
all right everyone's back and we're
about to have dinner look at this mama
would you make a fish come up here
sweet Chili's room - can hardly salivate
and I can make that feed and this looks
so pretty
haha yeah chicken feet soup oh that
sounds appetizing I don't remember yeah
you've had felt pretty good though yeah
okay
and then Diana made some drinks they
look like ready to feast we have a
little bit of chance I'm using two guys
had bent a little bit of
a tiny bit of sugar whose cucumber it
smells really good in here
I'm really hungry so I know girl I'm
hungry too let's eat all right it is
March something something something
tomorrow is March 17th right
that's name factor today yeah yeah and
we are drinking some proper Irish
whiskey proper 12 all right
Conor McGregor here's to you right you
can take a sip she would take a shot
are you trying probably are you the only
driver
[Music]